[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
le premier de la saison 2019 2020 on va
parler de foudre pas le municipal on va
parler des féminicides on va parler des
personnalités en hausse et on paie c'est
pour en parler alexandra rose éthique
bonjour lait de la mère de voisins
bretons deux vice présidents de la
communauté d'agglomération on va parler
tout à l'heure des municipales d'une
façon générale en france dans les
yvelines
notamment grâce à will freewifi
rédacteur en chef de cette scène est
justement de koné s'est lui montré très
bien la situation dans ce département et
vous nous direz quels sont les points à
suivre voilà qui montrait très chaud
pendant cesser la campagne des élections
municipales
stéphane manceau ça va bien mais oui
patrice oui oui ça va toujours
professeur à l'université de versailles
saint quentin il n'y a pas de raison on
n'a pas signifié mon congé on nous avait
promis de renvoyer donc là tout va bien
ça va et jean charles lajoie ni dirige
toujours l'édition la joie ni slogans
c'est une surprise absolue mme relations
vous n'êtes pas encore viré vous même à
la maison
on parlera d hier de deux livres que
vous venez de sortir tout à l'heure à la
rentrée littéraire
alors évidemment il ya beaucoup de
sujets qu'on peut aborder il ya un
événement c'est en effet la lutte contre
les féminicides la lutte contre les
femmes battues avec ce sentiment quand
même
assez présent que les choses n'avancent
pas est ce que c'est votre
est ce que c'est votre sentiment aussi
alexandre à haut débit je ne sais pas je
pense que des choses elles ont avancé
depuis quelques décennies quand même et
heureusement mais je pense aussi que
c'est un sujet qui est tellement
complexe que moi moi ce qui me frappe
c'est le sentiment que on attend tout de
l'état comme si l'état est un peu tout
puissant il pouvait régler tous les
problèmes je pense que l'état un rôle
très important à jouer évidemment et en
particulier dans l'accompagnement de ces
femmes sur la prévention il ya plein de
domaine sur lequel il peut jouer un rôle
mais je pense que c'est ce sont des
situations tellement complexe est
tellement mêmes spéciales et des
individuels et en même temps que c'est
c'est un ça va au-delà de ce que peut
faire ou ne pas faire
l'état je pense qu'il ya le côté
éducation qu'il me semble absolument
primordial parce que pourquoi un homme
bat sa femme c'est peut-être parce qu'il
l'a déjà vu dans son passé pour lui
c'est pas naturel mais voilà ça lui pose
pas de questions ou est-ce que c'est lié
à un phénomène d'addiction à la drogue
ou à l'alcool qui fait qu' il perd ses
repères et qu' il va passer à l'acte et
puis aussi aussi la femme
pourquoi la femme n'ose pas s'en aller
pourquoi est ce qu'elle est prête à
accepter ça est ce que c'est parce que
c'est plate l'étape vous aussi un rôle à
protéger plus physique
enfin je suis la profondeur je connais
une situation où je connais la situation
et je ne sais pas comment intervenir
parce que je sais que woods allongé sous
le site
aujourd'hui elle n'a pas envie voyez
donc les est compliqué on regarde de
loin on se dit bon comment intervenir
dans un couple quand on sait que la
personne qui est en difficulté et
peut-être sous emprise
et comment l'en sortir contre son preuve
sa propre volonté c'est pour ça que je
dis que bien sûr l'état doit mettre des
moyens bien sûr il doit accompagner ces
situations mais il ya aussi un problème
un phénomène à mon avis que voilà
comment je ne suis pas médecin donc je
ne ne maîtrise pas et aucun jugement
évidemment qui fait que certaines femmes
ont du mal à franchir le pas vous êtes
confrontés souvent en tant que maire à
ce jour de sa arrive plus souvent qu'on
pense en fait mais c'est toujours des
situations très douloureuses parce qu'on
s'en rend compte parfois quand c'est
trop tard ou quand c'est allé très loin
et que là vraiment on va nous appeler au
secours et heureusement qu'il ya des
structures pour accueillir dans votre
villa voisin il ya des structures il ya
une ambiance
voilà on a une association qui
et à qui on ou des appartements voisins
et qui est elle accueille justement des
femmes qui alors voisin c'est très très
modeste par rapport à d'autres villages
qui ont plus de structure je pense à
montigny en particulier mais voilà on à
ce moment là on sait vers qui se diriger
et elles peuvent être hébergées et
accompagner et là on a des associations
qui font un travail formidable aussi il
ya des tas mais il faut qu'il donne
aussi des moyens à ces associations
parce qu'elles elles vont s'occuper de
ces femmes et les aider à reprendre une
vie reprendre un travail
voilà parce qu'il ya aussi je pense un
phénomène peut-être de dépendants des
dépendances
il ya ici je trouve comment je vais
comment je veux vivre de ce que c'est
pour ça que c'est extrêmement et les
enfants voilà il ya plein de paramètres
qui font que des fois ça a l'air simple
de l'extérieur beaucoup s'en va pas bien
mais derrière il ya des situations
sociales ou psychologique
un peu individuel voilà donc je pense
que l'état oui alors moi j'entends des
sommes annoncées je ne sais pas quoi
elles correspondent
mais effectivement il faut que le moyen
de l'état sans doute renforcer les
moyens mais je pense que c'est un
problème de société et aussi
voilà aussi votre voisin vous savez
qu'il se passe quelque chose c'est
comment vous pouvez dans ce cas comment
intervenir aussi cela il est peut-être
leur cas c'est enfin une cellule à la
police nationale qui attrapent
d'ailleurs où on peut effectivement
contacté une personne la mettre au
courant lui dire ben voila je sais que
chez moi à côté de celle ci fera et pour
alerter la police et qu'elle sache en
plus si un appel faut vraiment le
prendre au sérieux
voilà d'authie il ya des choses c'est un
peu diffus on s'en rend pas forcément
compte mais il existe des choses
après on peut toujours faire plus j'en
suis convaincu mais voilà c'est toujours
on attend toujours énormément de buts et
bas les pouvoirs publics ont pas
toujours toutes les clés parce que c'est
complexe
c'était pas de nous là dessus ouais je
pense comme l'a dit alexandra aux eti je
pense en effet quand même les choses
n'avancent pas assez vite pas assez bien
mais enfin ça avance probablement comme
ça n'a jamais avancé
et au sujet moi je m'interrogeais au
sujet de ce terme féminicide mois ci
s'était inventé par une sociologue
oui mais je me dit deux choses la
première c'est que sur le plan juridique
il y avait déjà eu quelques quelques
réflexions à ce propos sur une une idée
qui consistait à se demander si on
pouvait inscrire ce terme dans le code
pénal et en vinyle infraction
particulière et la réponse est négative
négatif parce que je crois d'ailleurs
que le terme infanticide dans parricide
a été supprimé il ya le chauffeur
pénaliste atlantis il existe mais
parricide n'existe plus pour des
questions de fioul et d'universel de
conception universelle du droit et de et
d'égalité
oui à partir d'un moment il ya égalité
il ya la raison mais c'est vrai que d'un
autre côté je me dis que l'avènement de
ce terme n'est peut-être pas si négatif
que cela parce que ça permet quand même
de mettre le focus sur un phénomène dans
lequel on peut se dire quand même que il
ya ici une situation de relative
faiblesse en fin de force physique voire
parfois de force psychologique qui fait
que une femme peut être particulièrement
est spécifique
enfin vraiment spécialement victimes
oui mais en mettant l'accent sur
justement l'affût mini site c'est-à-dire
les morts de faim intervient vingt tous
les trois jours en gros est-ce que ça
occulte pas au foot certaines réalités
de la réalité des femmes battues c'est
beaucoup plus que ça parce que les
féminicides heureusement toutes les
femmes battues ne meurent pas je me
demande si en mettant l'accent sur ses
féminicide on n'occulte pas un peu la
réalité des choses sont les violences
faisaient violence ou alors ils peuvent
être aussi d'ordre biologique
tout à l'heure on parlait des structures
qui peuvent exister aussi
l'état peut pas tout faire il comme une
scène assez surréaliste aussi cette
semaine du président macron oui il se
rend dans une structure ces doutes le 39
19 sur la plateforme est qui et qui
constate une situation où le gendarme
mais la balle termine et le gendarme ne
veut pas intervenir et le président ont
fait passer des mots aux alaouites
communication existent ici faut
expliquer aux gendarmes qui peuvent
intervenir pour aller pour aider cette
femme allait rechercher c'est à faire
puisqu'elle quitté son domicile et
gendarmes n'a jamais voulu ça s'est
terminé comme ça donc je demande c'est
bien d'avoir une promotion
l'ajout du gendarme à vivre je suis tout
à fait d'accord avec avec madame la
seule fectivement sûr on en demande
beaucoup trop à l'étape il est temps de
pavant une réponse à tous je viens c'est
ici un abruti tape sur sa femme je
deviens l'état est quand même
relativement pour peu de peu de choses
qu après bien évidemment c'est
l'éducation commence qu'on en arrive à
penser n'auriez peut-être des sauveteurs
sont d'accord et bien sûr les sommes
effectivement mais le d'abord et vous le
disiez très justement tu as beaucoup de
femmes qui sont battus qu'ils ne sont
pas assassinés
heureusement donc le problème il est à
mon sens heureusement rien même temps il
sait que le problème plus les femmes
battues à mon sens que sur les
féminicides hockey féminin si c'est bien
évidemment horrible mais le fond du
problème c'est que les hommes continue à
taper sur la femme oui c'est ça quand
même en 2005 et l'année 2010 20h41 c'est
le vivant
c'est vrai que c'est pas sa preuve
rejaillit dans un passé quand même un
peu terrible que vient sondages on
pourrait penser que les hommes
s'améliore et bien sortez avec 27% des
jeunes qui pensent que on peut
légitimement faire plus sur sa femme
c'était une scène passant en plus on
peut on peut imaginer qu'il ya un bac
9h20 chiffres gouarin peu de gens qui
n'osent pas dire
qu'on pense pas moins mais qui dit bah
non bien sûr mais aimé la démo qui
prétendent à une vingtaine d'années dit
oui c'est normal tu puisses la femme
c'est quand même un peu inquiétant et ça
c'est pas l'état en tous cas c'est plus
profond que ça c'est dans cette ville du
cap sur ses relations en a fait un
certain milieu social c'était un
environnement c'est tout ça qui est
assez inquiétant
après sur le terme de féminicide oui moi
je trouve ça je suis ça permet de mettre
un accent sur sur ségolène royal qui est
absolument contre le terme de féminicide
pense qu'elle a raison et c'est certes
un petit peu ce que ce que tu disais
c'est aussi vrai pour coiffer
indifférence féminicide et c'est un
homicide et c est parce que sinon il ya
tendance j'imagine que dans des tas de
deux salons devant la télévision
informations d aubagne un centième
féminicide on est on imagine tout à fait
une à une elles sont bio web encore une
bonne femme qui s'est fait dessouder
quoi alors j'ai nommé il ya un côté bon
bah ouais à savoir nous en parlons nous
emmerde avec ça non c'est un vrai c'est
un véritable crime c'est pas un crime à
côté c'est pas un crime spécifique c'est
quelqu'un qui est tué jeudi dernier pas
d'eux parce que même à la marge il
inverse existe c'est à peut-être plus à
amara oui vous les hommes petit vous les
hommes battus ça existe aussi donc ça
veut dire une
si ce côté une association
j'ai repris sur ce plateau qui est à
maurepas et une femme dont le frère a
été victime qui se bat pour ça et qui
expliquent régulièrement quand on la
reçoit encore qu'aujourd'hui c'est un
tabou un homme battu assassiné l'homme
qui arrive et qui dit oui ma femme me
ben alors là il est traité plus bas que
terre par là tout le monde se moque t-on
telle évoqué ségolène royal mais où
va-t-il
il l'a pris je ne sais pas alors aimons
nous les uns les autres
bah c'est un peu l'événement c'est ce
qui va se passer aux municipales
[Rires]
peut-être d'abord avait avec vous ses
fans manceau les municipales en
politique
qu'est ce que ça nous dire ce que c'est
important politiquement c'est très
compliqué patrice près que alors trois
jeux juste trois observations votre
votre observation question la première
c'est que
les élections municipales ça ne vous
aura pas échappé se déroule tout en même
temps
et pourtant ça concerne 35 mille huit
cent une fois je sais plus où on en est
c'est maria à 86,36 ça on est rarement
ça fait des années des siècles qu'on
n'était pas descendu au dessous de 37 et
or cette cette situation là elle date
sur l'échelle du temps d'une période
relativement va pas pas si récente que
cela met de la fin du 19e siècle avant
alors il n'y a pas de suffrage universel
à on votait au suffrage censitaire pour
le conseil municipal et le maire était
pour les grandes villes nommées par le
gouvernement et pour les villes moins
importantes nommé par le préfet mais en
tout cas pour les élections municipales
les élections avaient lieu de manière
totalement dispersé commune par commune
si bien que ce scrutin était à peu près
ciblées et est nationalement invisible
ça se déroulait de temps à autre de
manière totalement de des origines et
voulait à partir des années 1880 90
c'est l'état qui a dit ben maintenant
les élections municipales auront lieu
partout au même moment le même les mêmes
dimanche pour si vous voulez le
l'objectif c'était de de permettre à
l'état à cette époque-là d'imprimer sa
marque sur ce qu'on appellera plus tard
les collectivités locales ne s'appelait
pas encore comme sa collectivité ça
faisait trop ça semblait leur donner
trop de pouvoir donc il ya une espèce
d'effet de simuler l'effet de loupe
c'est en réalité 36000 scrutin qui se
déroule tous en même temps
mais dans trente six mille lieux
différents avec des sociologie
électorale est complètement différente
avec des problèmes des questions d huile
et villages extrêmement différents donc
il y à cet effet si vous voulez qui est
très
qui est trompeur il ya un effet
déformant qui laisse à croire que le
peuple souverain se prononce dans un
seul et même élan alors que c'est une
une 35000 fraction de samedi se brise
qui s'expriment scrutin différent
voilà la deuxième observation montre qu'
il est extrêmement difficile de tirer
des enseignements des résultats des
élections municipales et d'opérer des
projections sur des pronostics relatif à
l'installation en prime celle où
législatives alors j'ai regardé
anticipant votre question et je me suis
aperçu qu'en effet il n'ya pas de
corrélation vraiment aisé vraiment
facile et il a même parfois des
contradictions je me suis avoir
l'élection delanoë par exemple maire de
paris et jospin n'est pas au deuxième
tour deux ans plus tard ou regarder
alors un peu plus ou un inventeur en
1977 77 et les fêtes 17h10 re non
certains oui c'est une vague de boue
sans précédent de la gauche de gauche 78
qui perdent les de la gauche socialiste
un qui détrône brouillonne les mairies
communistes je suis assez terne mais un
événement enfin il y avait absolue et
celui qui était des bastions de la
droite qu'à la gauche donc tout le monde
se dit ils vont garder des législatives
après manon en 78 les dizaines ont tout
fait pour pas les gagner aussi m'enfin
bon goût et le le fameux l'appel au bon
choix
réveil de garder qu'un jusqu'à regagné
1,78 et enfin troisième et dernière
observation c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que
au regard de la très grande
fragmentation du paysage communal en
france des 80 % des communes qui
comptent moins de 1000 habitants
quand même encore en détails et de
l'intercommunalité etc
et puis des processus de fusion qui ont
lieu et qu'ils sont plutôt un succès
mais qui concerne à peu près 2000
communes sur les 35000 donc de saluer
très grande fragmentation pouvait pas
mettre dans un même sac
donc les 80% de communes de moins de
2000 habitants et les les quinze mille
communes lesparre dont les 500 communes
de plus de 10 mille habitants il est
seulement 500 communes de plus de 10
mille habitants donc il faut savoir où
regarder
alors si c'est si on veut chercher des
résultats significatifs c'est peut-être
dans ce lot des communes de plus de 10
mille habitants parce que les collègues
en sciences politiques considèrent je
sais pas si c'est pas un peu arbitraire
mais qu'il y a vraiment un
un vrai champ politique structurée sur
ce seuil de dix mille habitants en deçà
ça serait placé beaucoup plus local est
local dray et puis au delà il y aurait
un personnel politique un peu entre
guillemets un peu professionnalisé avec
un corps électoral plus plus plus
structurée autour de caisse de grandes
questions politiques
donc c'est ses fins c'est toujours
extrêmement délicat s'ils voulaient
tirer des traits de tirer les
enseignements
et puis il ya une ultime observations
j'ai regardé aussi on dit c'est parfois
résultats globaux la gauche l'emportent
où la droite l'emportent
lorsque la gauche ne l'emportent 77 88
c'est à 51% 51% toutes communes
confondues il est passé lorsque la
droite l'emportent clairement toutes les
autres hypothèses
elles l'emportent à 60 à 70% donc d'où
aussi la grande stabilité du cenajes bel
sénat et oui qui a été lu à 95% par les
conseillers municipaux pour la plupart
des conseillers municipaux chambre qui
est politiquement très stable
juste une petite parenthèse de trois ans
mais avec la pousser une petite poussée
de la gauche dans les dents les dans les
grandes villes mais voyez il ya ce ce
déséquilibre
extrêmement important du paysage quasi
d'avril oui alors on va parler de la
situation avec vous wilfrid incidents
dans les yvelines mais vous vous achevez
votre premier mandat de m alors vous
étiez déjà élu avant donc c'est pas une
découverte va qu'est ce qui vous a
surpris on voit aussi beaucoup de mères
qui ne vont plus se représenter parce
que la charge est lourde parce que ils
ont formé pour ça parce que les les
habitants leur demande des choses très
contradictoires et difficile à résoudre
votre sentiment comme ça de demers à
papa je ne parle pas de politique je
parle pas d'élection je parle de la
fonction je suis assez d'accord avec ce
que disent les mères c'est à dire que
bon un moment dans ce sondage là on a
mis en avant le fait que l'état donné
moins de moyens c'est vrai que nos
dotations globales elles elles diminuent
d'année en année voir on va aller à 0 à
un moment ou un autre
donc ça c'était un petit peu mis sur le
dos de l'état puis maintenant
effectivement commencé à entendre des
mères qui disent bah oui mais les
administrés sont extrêmement exigeants
et en fait je ça c'est quelque chose que
je vis subtilement au quotidien et je
pense que c'est dû aussi à la
méconnaissance du pouvoir des voix
rumeurs et oui parce que non je parle
j'en parlais tout à l'heure pour l'état
on a besoin de ce maire il peut tout
alors je donne un exemple très concret
linky l'installation des compteurs linky
alors à voisins ça doit commencer ça
devait être en cours en fin ça a
commencé en mai et
tout d'un coup tout le monde s'est fait
il ya beaucoup de gens qui se sont mis à
m'écrire en me disant il faut vous
interdisez et pourquoi sauf que je n'ai
pas le droit d'interdire puisque après
il ya tout un débat sur d'où ça vient
kehlois est-ce que c'est l'europe parce
que c'est obligatoire pas obligatoire
etc mais maison avant que j'avais tous
les pouvoirs que je pouvais dire a alors
j'avais fait voter un voeu en conseil
municipal justement pour dire que nous
demandions à inédite de le faire que si
les gens étaient d'accord
après il ya des gens qui peuvent vouloir
c'est chacun est libre et il ya une et
dix à a voulu attaquer se veut en disant
non non non c'est pas légal
donc j'ai pas voulu embarquer la commune
dans des défis parce que je vois bien
toutes les communes qui vont traiter
alterne donc je vérifie retirer 2 après
on a eu un débat avec kennedy j'ai mis
le compte rendu du débat en ligne sur la
ville pour que les gens aient de la
formation mais c'était flagrant c'est à
dire que c'est fait on verra où on se
retourne il ya pas mal de situations
comme ça et alors ce qui est encore plus
complexe
est ce que les autres maires soulignent
aussi c'est que comme nous sommes en
intercommunalité ça multiplie pour finir
on délègue les compétences donc ça
multiplie les intervenants dont il ya
des voiries ou c'est la ville qui
intervient d'autres où c'est
l'agglomération
donc forcément on n'est pas dans le même
tempo
donc les gens comprennent pas forcément
et pourquoi ma rue je peux pas l'avoir
tout de suite et pourquoi je peux pas
avoir mes trois poteaux et c'est donc
après on travaille que l'agglomération
qui fait ce qu'elle peut pour
effectivement réagir au plus vite mais
mais il ya sept mois je me suis amusé à
publier dans le journal pendant ce
mandat par quartier qui gérait quoi
parce qu'il ya des fois où on a des
effets des copropriétaires des fois ça
la copropriété après la rue ça va être
la ville après les espaces verts savent
être l'agglomération pour que les gens s
comprennent cette complexité et s'il
faudrait pas simplifié alors peut-être
là d'un moment on franchement alors nous
nous à 50 ans on a de la chance ça fait
longtemps qu'on est en tout cas les sept
communes historique est bon qu'il et les
autres se sont intégrés mais donc on a
cette culture depuis longtemps mais
j'imagine
l'agglomération ils sont 70 75 nous on
est 12 à 12 on commence à arriver à
s'entendre qui à se connaître et 75
je veux dire pour un maire c'est
désespérant en plus ça multiplie les
réunions dont vous êtes déjà quand même
pas mal pris par votre commune en plus
vous allez faire des réunions il ya des
transferts de compétences où on voit pas
forcément tout de suite l'intérêt france
aujourd'hui en ménagère à voisins pour
nous c'est pas intéressant ça augmente
notre payx pour un service qui peut
diminuer donc comment voulez vous
expliquer ça aux tendons on n'a pas tous
les pouvoirs et les gens me disent mais
oui mais vous êtes de vice-présidente
donc vous pouvez agir sur les taux
on est soixante quinze voisin il ya
quatre élus c'est pas les quatre voies
de voisins qui vont faire parce que
voyez donc qu'il ya un problème de
compréhension pour les gens n'ont pas
forcément le temps de s'y intéresser à
fond non plus donc c'est assez complexe
d'enseigner le maire c'est le lait lui a
porté deux gifles langue est l'arabe
c'est là ma personne qu'on vient de voir
woods et après c'est normal ça fait
partie de notre travail et heureusement
en fait il ya toujours cet échelon de
proximité
ouais mais est en même temps celle ellul
préféré un des français soit je radote
voit la difficulté des relations entre
les les français le maire reste quand
même celui qui est préservée en valais
il est tout de suite disponible il va
répondre tout de suite après quand on
répond et qu'on a un peu un aveu
d'impuissance
je vais un autre exemple les gens du
voyage moi les gens du voyage et
s'installa voisins depuis deux ans il
force les terrains il force il rentre il
s'installe l'année dernière ça a été un
tollé parce que les luges explique aux
gens que une fois que les caravanes ont
des clés moi je peux plus rien faire
donc il a fallu le faire comprendre
parce que c'était je ne faisais rien
c'était scandaleux etc
mais après on fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour les faire partir ou pour gérer les
choses mais voilà donc ça fait c'est
l'état a cédé tard voilà donc jeu
vous pas me défausser sur l'état mais
voilà c'est quand même pas par simple à
comprendre
et alors c'est une fonction sur beaucoup
de maires des as et vous valorisante
enfin pour ceux qui l'exercent parce
qu'on voit ce qu'on fait portent des
projets voilà l'avertissement pas
toujours mes enfants voilà on peut voir
l'aboutissement et puis il faut aimer
les gens en fait donc si on aime le
contact avec les gens pas forcément on a
un métier ne s'investit pas un métier
c'est une fonction dans laquelle on peut
s'épanouir
mais voilà il faut faire preuve de
pédagogie parce que tout n'est pas aussi
simple qu'on pourrait le penser quoi
alors passer aux eyzies been peut-être
un petit mot sur paris parce qu'on voit
delgo qui resteront en tentant du poil
de la bête
peut-être du poil de la pat quinn juvisy
ya en tout cas vu une difficulté à
s'entendre en face quoi oui oui mais
c'est une chance chauffin j'imagine
inouïe pour anne hidalgo fin il ya un an
je dire plus personne j'ai c'est son
premier adjoint sandales et en claquant
la porte en disant que tu es un
autocrate
enfin bon j'ai écrit c'était monstrueux
pas très élevé qu elle enfin les gens se
plaignaient de tous et a raison mais
enfin je veux dire
la ville est quand même un infesté était
infesté est infesté de rats et c'est
l'impression que les intérêts et que et
que les rats non mais ça fait exactement
vrai mais que faire des albums alors
qu'elles devraient dératiser la réparer
on va pas faire un débat sur le
cinquième but voiture pour les écraser
donc les participants il ya tellement
draps à paris qu'ils sont option paniqué
parce que si on arrivait à tous les tuer
comme un rat avant d'aller mourir il va
se planquer dans les endroits absolument
inatteignable parc par quiconque
donc ce serait pestilentielles se
seraient des rats crevés partout et je
crois qu'il ya 6 millions de rats à
paris donc 6 millions draps vous vous
imaginez six millions de rats qui meurt
et qu'on peut pas attraper qu'on veut
pas dégagé c'est donc c'est un véritable
problème enfin bon on y reviendra dessus
si vous voulez maintenant
l'intérêt de beaucoup seulement sur
l'aim duras et pour en revenir à anne
hidalgo elle a quand même une chance
inouïe parce que bon je veux dire
villani et griveaux fin j'ai des
réponses vont s'entre déchirer mais
c'est pas de wii l'année parce que les
éco guide for villani il ya beaucoup de
gens qui pensent qu'il peut faire ce cas
ces macro présidentielle c'est partir
sans être investis et pas par la partie
est gagnée quand même parce que il ya eu
quand même une tribune signée par
beaucoup d'intellectuels français
c'est une image quand même villani dans
le monde
oui le drame dont un fils de m à paris
je sais pas il ya eu des ya eu des
dessins bon peu tu es verts de paris
une tradition aussi intellectuelle dans
paris quand même et de telles qu'elles
représentent longtemps qu'on voit plus
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment vous expliquer quand même la
capacité de la droite qui est tenue
cette mairie de paris pendant longtemps
notamment avec avec jacques chirac à
s'organiser à trouver un candidat
là elle est éparpillé façon puzzle enfin
oui entre temps je crois que je crois
que c'est un peu symptomatiques d'une
je pense que l'élection de macron est là
elle a déclenché quelque chose qui est
un petit peu symptomatiques et qui est
en train de pousser dans notre pays
c'est à dire que les partis ils sont pas
ils sont plus aussi important que ça moi
quand j'étais élu j'avais aucune
investiture
voilà après dès que j'étais élu j'étais
le maire rudy mai et après des parties
viennent vers nous on est certain c est
que je suis pas la seule dans ce cas là
donc ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
le les gens se tournent plus vers les
partis je pense pour trouver des
solutions à leurs problèmes parce que on
a eu tellement d'histoires d'affaires je
crois qu'il ya une espèce de lassitude
et que c'est ensemble où tu vas je sais
mon analyse personnelle sans doute les
ans vont plus vers une personnalité
iraient keller pas oui c'est parce qu'il
ya des sources qui leur parlent plus que
vers un parti les femmes en sont tout à
l'heure c'est pas forcément une bataille
politique que la droite à gauche alors
les parties de se reconstituer parce
qu'il faudrait qu'ils trouvent une main
leader un peu charismatique vais la
droite parisienne et quand même terrible
d'algues au quai de gauche qui se
revendique de gauche qu'il est
effectivement en face ça c'est de cécile
j'aime beaucoup mâcon par ailleurs et
c'est quand même une erreur fondamentale
de macron de ne jamais avoir pris de
décision sur paris d avoir laissé
s'entredéchirer de ne pas avoir été
capable de dire de devoir villani en
disant voilà qu'est ce que tu veux
vraiment faire ce qu'ils ont dit que
c'est pas un peu ce que fait il est
quand même député la république en place
le vide année dépassant parties
n'arrivent pas donc grille vous voulez
rire pas exclu de marcher ça veut peut
dire de dire des choses aussi mais ça
veut dire que franchement là dessus
mcnamara qui a tenu quand même à y
mettre à mal joué c'est quand même
terrible fallait elle est totalement
éclatés là bas ce qui est dingue qui
vous râlez avec avec en marche elle a
d'autres qui vont essayer de faire des
listes eux-mêmes enfin ça va ça va être
très compliqué pour mon avis il faudrait
une personnalité à paris de droite
tomber ça alors parlons des vides
alors quelle est la situation générale
on peut dire en 2014 2014
c'est la droite parlementaire qui arrive
en tête c'est aussi le cas dans le
département des yvelines il ya plusieurs
communes qui bascule de gauche à droite
le site des carrières sous poissy
conflans sainte honorine et maurepas
également et puis d'autres sont même
passés sous le bastion de l'ex front
national aujourd'hui rassemblement
national grâce notamment à des divisions
en face c'est le cas de mantes-la-ville
ça des répercussions ensuite sur la
composition des agglomérations
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ensuite est
passé pour la première fois sous le
giron de la droite ce n'est pas le cas
avant et puis aujourd'hui c'est plus
tout à fait la même chose forcément il
ya quand même eu l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 qui a changé un
peu les choses parti socialiste
républicain dont des élus des maires qui
ont quitté laurent qui sont rapprochés
des règles macron dit à d'autres
formations qui ont fait leur apparition
aussi on va parler de la france
insoumise mia génération aussi par
exemple maire de magny les hameaux sur
sa boutique en évidence est venu
génération fallait rester fidèle de
suite quel est ce qu elle expliqué en
tout cas les uns les autres vont se
présenter mais ce que disait alexandre
est dédié l'étiquette c'est important ou
pas mais auparavant non plus il ya
souvent des listes divers droite divers
gauche sans étiquette et souvent même au
moment de l'inscription en préfecture
qui aime bien quand même cataloguer les
choses il ya toujours un conflits et
litiges et il est assez courant que même
une fois l'enregistrement faire en
préfecture les listes appel en disant
oui mais nous on préférait vous nous
présentiez comme divers droite divers
gauche il à l air humide et aussi du
ministre l'intérieur
exactement ce que vous décrivez c'est à
dire le la cartographie politique des
déclarations de candidature et vous
observez que jusqu'à présent en tout cas
les grands partis ps
les républicains ou unités avant pc etc
les grands partis il ya très longtemps
sont ultra minoritaires face à divers
gauche divers droite domine mais
vraiment d'une manière très très
très très marquée des scrutins de liste
on leur précise pas sur mais c'est un
scrutin de listes à l'eau ils servent
ces portée par une personnalité une tête
de liste mais après les électeur ne
votera pour le maire directement ils
votent pour une livre ensuite le conseil
municipal église palmer mais quand même
dans leur esprit il atteste de lien avec
mon esprit d'escalier mais tout à
l'heure on avait eu un schéma sur paris
alors où c'est pire parce que là c'est
par un rebondissement
et c'est pas celui qui a forcément le
plus de voix qui était gagné l'élection
la dernière fois je crois que monsieur
sco morizet avait moins de voix que les
dalles gosl d'aldo qui était bien parce
qu'elle a remporté plus tard bouddhisme
est alors le plus usé que l'oci et des
écolos ils peuvent aussi
considérablement changé la donne on va
voir si effectivement j'ai tellement
enthousiasmé les femmes et des
européennes
est-ce que ça plaît ce le rhume et ville
où ils sont de 9 1%
si on changeait de tonnes par
concrètement lors 205 et des communes
sur lesquelles on va mettre de la
province pour la bonne bouche dans
quelles sont les villes qui ou que vous
allez regarder quoi ville de versailles
notamment c'est une ville qui est ancré
à droite le maire françois de mazières
alors s'il se représente
aura-t-il vous n'aura-t-il pas un
soutien de la république en marche ça
peut paraître compliqué je faisais les
candidats françois de mazières en tout
cas on ne sait pas quel investiture il
aura mai
c'est surtout que son il y avait la vida
voilà son candidat pour les élections
européennes c'était françois xavier
bellamine et on imagine mal la
république surtout qu'après il faudrait
aussi faire avec le député lrm de la
circonscription qui est didier baichère
et qui lui aussi est élu au conseil
municipal de versailles voilà donc tout
ça on verra pour le jeu des étiquettes
il ya aussi les risques le tgv cher
voilà pour l'instant sur saint germain
en laye le maire emmanuel lamy qui a
passé la main c'est en 2017 c'est arnaud
péricard qui a pris le relais
alors lui il est très macro compatible
aux siens il va certainement avoir cette
investiture de la république l'a de la
république en marche il a même signé une
tribune en juin dernier pour appeler au
succès à la réussite du gouvernement
voici aussi un peu le même cas avec oui
mais non et karl olive dans les
dernières rumeurs n'aurait pas forcément
le soutien de la république en a préfacé
par mâcon forcément c'est un peu
compliqué rappelle tout de même que karl
olive est aussi très proche de pierre
bédier qui est le président de conseil
d'état et qui lui est républicain donc
ensuite sur une fois les soutiens
accordés il faut aussi pour la
république en marche garder cet
équilibre entre républicains socialistes
gauche droite voilà karl olive et qui
avait soutenu juppé ou au président
certains subissent tombak rocco battu
sur le fil va après après il ya et c'est
vrai qu'il ya des enjeux locaux aussi
donc c'est pas forcément ça va ça ne va
pas forcément de soi quoi sur le cas de
rambouillet a appuyé sa version cc
larcher suppléant russell à la ville de
ségou rick jeu même si le président du
sénat gérard larcher aujourd'hui c'est
marc robert qui porte cette commune mais
agile schmidt qui est un ancien udi
d'ailleurs qui est le suppléant
aujourd'hui d'horreur berger à
l'assemblée nationale qui porte la
candidature république en marche lui il
a été investi il a déjà le soutien et
l'investiture de la république en marche
mais voilà qui se présentera en cela
qu'ils intéressent vraiment on imagine
la république en marche aussi disposer
un petit peu ses pions sur les
différentes communes on a évoqué aussi
son nom pour le coup de doreur berger ça
reste les rumeurs les offres qu'on
entend un peu pendant la campagne
candidate sur une liste à maurepas
pourquoi pas sur une liste à maurepas et
pourquoi pas sur la liste du maire
pourquoi pas donc après un bon premier
parentèle de dioxines et plus et je
tiens à les voler qui resterait débuté
mais en tout cas qui pourrait se placer
sur sur cette liste du maire goerig
arrestier grimaud reggae restiez
républicains tout cas pour l'instant ce
qu'il pourrait aussi quitter l'est
républicain voilà quel équilibre
ensuite derrière tout ça forcément ça
compliquerait ensuite les rapports au
sein de l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines jean michel fourgous le
président lui républicain il le reste ça
va jouer là dessus et lui aussi se
présente parce que là on évoque toute
cette commune mais en fait l'enjeu
surtout je me tourne vers vous c'est
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
finalement que oui si on reste serein
dangereuse saint quentin en yvelines
c'est l'enjeu c'est de savoir qui va
travailler avec qui quelle que soit
l'étiquette que ce république en marche
que ce soit l air que soit ps peu
importe finalement si surtout que tous
ces gens là vont devoir travailler
ensemble et dégager une majorité ensuite
pour agir parce que ya pas de majorité
pas de décision c'est compliqué trouvera
on trouvera quoi qu'il arrive de toute
façon c'est oui parce que si elle l'a
aussi vaillancourt le on peut l'analyser
politiquement endroit d'où cette terre
mais on peut l'analyser différemment
c'est le fonctionnement fait sortir à un
moment tu dois y avoir des majorités
surtout dans les dents les intercoms oui
dans les rangs radicaux ne dit pas ce
que c'est beau c'est impossible
les clivages politiques sont assez peu
marqué même dans les très grande interco
qui peuvent être clan mais bien sûr ils
ont été marqués à saint-quentin parce
que s'était tenue par la gauche pense
pas longtemps la création et deviendrait
donc là il ya une alternance mais eh
bien parlons sera pas le cas déjà benoît
hamon benoît hamon c'est sa commune il
s'y était présenté tout cas il était sur
la liste
si on était député de l'hérault et
député de la circonscription et si on
regarde les derniers scrutins soient
présidentielle ou encore les européennes
derrière le score des listes en tout cas
de la candidature benoît hamon ce sont
des bons scores sera très bon score et
surtout il a réalisé un bon score dont
qui pourrait aussi présenter non mais
par rapport à la mi mai dans le calme
pas franchement un bon score non mais
bon sens s'il arrivait sur les communes
sur la commune de trappes aux
européennes sauf erreur j'ai plus le
chiffre en tête avant peut-être sont les
européennes sur sa commune alors elle
pourrait se remettre dans le cadre aussi
de la participation ou sur cette ville
qui est officieusement la forte
abstention
donc il se pourrait se présenter en tout
cas est ce qu'il sera ou non sur la
liste de dali rabais ali rabais qui est
conseiller municipal de la majorité mais
que si le porte parole national de
benoît du mouvement générations donc en
tout cas lui se présentera une autre
candidature rajouter c'est contre ma
langue contre malandain qui lui a alors
essayé la candidature c'est qu'on puisse
dire dali rabais aussi ok il ya division
à gauche il ya déjà une division et puis
au sein du conseil municipal il ya aussi
un ancien membre de la majorité qui qui
a quitté donc la majorité de gauche qui
a plutôt maintenant un soutien
république en marche qui était co
animateur de la république en mars sur
le secteur qui a annoncé son ralliement
à othman al othmane nasri ou républicain
conseiller régional aussi et lui attrape
le conseil régional proche de valérie
pécresse voilà donc sans que sur 3
valeurs et mustapha larfaoui qui fait
qu'ils pourraient venir commenté à sa
décision lorsqu'elle interviendra pour
l'instant il a dit qu'il irait mais sur
quelle liste
sourire et met pas en tête soit le virer
en tête 6 notamment corps avec personne
soit ils se rejoindront me rejoindre à
l'un des candidats
la menace rooney rabais il lui aussi
pourrait de par ce doc savage moisir sur
la commune sur la ville de trappes ça
risque d'être assez assez magique non et
puis après sur les yvelines faut aussi
regarder du côté de mantes la ville
oui on voir si son relationnel
séparation des eaux nationales qu'on va
réussir a profité une nouvelle fois des
divisions ou au contraire même au delà
même de la division sis en face il
arrivait à se mettre d'accord sur une
candidature un temps il était même
évoqué une candidature commune gauche
droite
voilà pour faire face au front national
au rassemblement national voilà ils vont
réussir à conserver cette seule commune
c'est la seule commune de la région qui
avait basculé rassemblement
assemblée nationale sur l'île de france
voilà on pourrait parler de
voisins-le-bretonneux candidat voulait
j'ai pas trop droit parce qu'on est en
période pré candidate pas candidat oui à
tout candidat là mais sans parler de
spécifique probable s'il fait sur doit
donc puisque en effet vous êtes des fabs
est vice président de la communauté d
agglomération il y a est ce ce qui s'est
passé il ya une stratégie politique de
2,2 des gens qui gouvernent
l'agglomération ou pas sur le sur les
élections municipales
non je crois que là chacun s'observe un
petit peu pour voir laquelle vont être
les forces en présence qui va y aller
qui potentiel quelle ville
potentiellement pourrait changer de bord
parce que dans les deux sens
il ya des voix il ya des risques ou je
ne sais pas si c'est ça qui est ça des
risques et enfin vous savez sans doute
place voilà donc je pense qu'il ya
quelques communes effectivement où il va
y avoir un point d'interrogation parce
que peut-être beaucoup de listes aussi
que c'est un peu difficile d'acquis
profits de la division bon à paris c'est
anne hidalgo attrape je ne sais pas je
ne fais ça c'est très très difficile de
pronostiquer donc chose que s'il n'y a
pas deux aujourd'hui et pas stratégie au
niveau intercommunal proprement parler
puisqu'il faut que chaque maire se
déclare enfin ceux qui le suivent partir
ce qui veut donc c'est un petit peu
encore encore un peu flou moi par contre
ce qui me frappe c'est le discours
justement qui tend à dire que ce qui
s'est passé aux européennes va se passer
aux municipales c'est à dire la
tradition c'est voilà alors l'écologie
ça là dessus je crois que déjà dans le
scrutin précédent l'écolo l'écologie
avait fait aussi un bon score aux
aux européennes le meilleur score qu'ils
aient fait c'était cohn-bendit 16
là oui ça arrive et c'est pas parce que
c'est bien ce tracé au musellement des
relais verte voilà c'est aussi un signal
à prendre eux et bien évidemment est
d'autant plus que je pense que beaucoup
de jeunes ont voté pour ce parti
évidemment parce que bah ils savent que
en 2050 la situation se dégrade
c'est eux qui vont être en première
ligne non je pense qu'ils sont d'autant
plus sensibles à l'écologie
et donc c'est vraiment quelque chose que
fait tous les élus tous bords confondus
bien entendu d'autres trains en compte
et c'est évident de là à dire que des
listes écologiques vont faire leur
apparition et gagner les communes non
mais elle vaut peut-être besoin et elles
vont peu voilà mais c'est peut-être
l'intérêt de ce scrutin européen face à
face aux émissaires la composition des
listes en tout cas les sensibilités ou
les parties écologie peut aussi venir
vous voir en disant on aimerait bien des
gens en position éligible aussi voir des
gens qui pourrait aussi rejoindre
l'agglomération 50 ans nuit je trouve
que c'est ces tractations c'est toujours
un petit peu complexe je pense qu'il
faut que que quand quelqu'un vient sur
une liste b il vient parce qu'ils
partagent le projet il partage la
philosophie de la liste non pas faire un
patchwork de mon équipe voilà il ya les
gens qui veulent s'afficher s'affichent
les ans qui veulent pas ils le font pas
du moment qu'on partage les mêmes
valeurs et le même projet moi c'est ça
qui m'intéresse c'est que les
tractations politiques bon mais existent
elles existent des risques on s'est
montré très bien les autres ont parlé
des écologistes mis en marche aussi il
vaut peut-être pas on sait pas ses mots
reporter des villes ou pas mais c'est
important pour un parti qui n'est
représenté que nationalement par des
députés de prendre appui dans les
communes d'avoir des élus les
sénatoriales
denner au moins qui puisse heurter les
agglomérations j'ai par exemple au fur à
mesure ça c'est forcément pas uniquement
sur ce scrutin la mesure alors on
parlait des oeuvres parler un peu de la
droite puisque lui diy lui dsk 12h
appartient à la droite d'ailleurs ou au
centre
alors ça sent très bon aujourd'hui je
dis c'est pas c'est pas le parti qui a
le plus besoin c'est la scission
c'était des gens qui soutenez bayrou aux
présidentielles de 2007 me semble t'il
et écran bayrou ne s'est pas désisté
pour 20 n'a pas appelé à voter pour
pour sarkozy certains noms devaient lui
qui était notamment des députés ont créé
lui dei pour faire cette partition du
centre soutenus de sarkozy j'ai résumé
après essai inclus et le parti radical
voit la fin travail a vu aussi ce moment
de huy parti radical réunifiée mais qui
vient compliquer quand même s'en séparer
de douala donc pour moi c'est au
centre-droit c'est centre-droit et donc
c'est un parti qui doit aussi quelque
part se refonder visiblement elle ne
s'est pas loupé non plus le lala
laventure des européennes qui a été
menée par la garde
m'ayant donné les résultats qu'on sait
visiblement il ya un changement parce
que là ils vont faire des alliances avec
la république en marche pour les pour
les municipales ce qui est compliqué
c'est que lui dit qu' il comme
indépendants vous avez fait librement
les indépendances et non longtemps rangé
sous la culte de des républicains avant
voit la commune la gare de toul un jour
décidé d'exister euros aux européennes
alors moi j'étais plutôt content mais je
me suis dit ça y est on va exister bon
quand on voit le score qu'on a fait
évidemment c'était compliqué avec
parking la liste le doc c'est un petit
peu mais je me disais oh moi
enfin on essaye d'exister par nous-mêmes
c'était quand même c'était quand même un
intérieur très bon c était ça c'est un
parti qui doit aussi peut-être se
reposer des questions sur où il veut
aller
ce qu'il est vraiment indépendants s qui
doit donc après les alliances avec en
marche ou avec les républicains
aujourd'hui au conseil départemental
c'est l'est républicain elodie
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment une alliance
et on est dans la majorité dont vous
imposer au niveau national aussi des
alliances et on y parlait des alliances
au niveau national de l'udps et est-ce
que ensuite petit coup de téléphone pour
vous dire bon ok vous vous accordez en
local mais il faudra quand même faire
figurer des élus république en marche
parce qu'on s'est mis d'accord avec la
république alors je ne sais pas monsieur
lagarde a pas mon téléphone je sais pas
exactement comment ça va se passer mais
ces doutes car être dépendants oui moi
je garde mon indépendance parce que
parce que je connais la difficulté de
mener une équipe parce que c'est facile
de se dire on se met avec untel untel
parce qu'il ya des intérêts médéric est
allé dans le sens derrière vous menez
une équipe et donc vous menez des êtres
humains qui ont tous leur façon de voir
les choses et si vous n'avez pas eu un
socle commun un moment ou un autre c'est
compliqué donc moi je pense que c'est ça
qui doit prévaloir
alors après moi je rassemblement
national n'ont évidemment la france est
soumise non plus d'ailleurs mais c'est
les extrêmes ne m'intéresse pas mais
c'est les valeurs qui doivent doivent
nous porter à mon sens accord donc moi
s'il monsieur lagarde m'appelle en me
disant il faut que tu prennes untel et
untel
oui peut toujours à moins qu'un tel ou
tel soit alexandre et que personnalité
justement mais dans les difficultés de
la droite il ya un des projets s'essuie
de l'archer notamment lé de baroin qui
veut repartir dès territoires où truc
c'est plutôt une bonne idée où s'est
propagée enfin sais pas ce que ça veut
dire
je ne sais pas trop parce que repartir
de territoire c'est bien mais ils y sont
déjà
c'est là la droite si un argumentaire
tient une immense majorité des communes
de plus de 15000 habitants depuis les
dernières municipales tient presque
toutes les régions et une immense part
des départements donc repartir d oui
m'enfin allons-y allez-y enfin jeu mais
c'est cette idée est toujours très
président du sénat aussi une grande une
grande figure le ça est ce qu'on disait
du sénat.le l'assemblée du seigle et de
la châtaigne c'est le porte parole du
local etc et pour en contrepoids ce
président jupitérien qui vient d'en haut
on ne sait pas d'où il vient mais voilà
il est arrivé comme ça d'en haut
nous on va essayer se distille de partir
d'en bas l'internement l'internement pas
où il a failli dire savoir à cet avion
cette annonce est la référence à peu
court
je ne sais pas car franchement c'était
c'était pour des bêtes à revenir à la
terre de glace et un pour vous inciter à
imiter
hi media oui le maréchal de goya mais
non c'est vrai c'est toujours cette idée
de du thym vieillesse est un hommage à
cette île et d'écouté pas le terrain
dont on parle souvent et du voilà
j'aimerais savoir ce que c'est que le
ter comble présence est bien dans les
territoires il ya orléans par exemple
cette commission formule trop habile et
quelqu'un élite livre de max ou pas je
suis entendu parler comme tout le monde
y a pas besoin de l'avoir dérobé de
rajouter donc voilà qu'en dire moi le
personnage de yann moix absolument
antipathique le c'est pas très grave
après ça reste un écrivain et un
écrivain romancier il a le droit de dire
ce qu'il veut il s'est marqué sur la
couverture de son livre est un roman
donc qui raconte ce qu'il veut dans son
livre il n'a pas marqué récit est pas
marqué autobiographie il n'a pas marqué
c'est la vérité c'est pas un
documentaire
c'est un roman il peut raconter
n'importe quoi sur ses parents sur tout
le monde voilà c'est sont tissés fausse
d'un bon romancier si c'est vrai il ya
sûrement faire donc deux trames
absolument après je vais maintenant que
tout a été déballée un breillat il ya le
passé le frère a surgi mais les textes
antisémites
deux polonais et maintenant je vois un
qui paraît qu'il y aurait aussi des
textes contre les noirs voilà qu'on va
exhumer donc après elle s'appelle
surtout un commentaire important c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens après son
cette séance un peu masochiste chez
ruquier ou l'a dit je n'étais qu'une
merde je suis une saloperie fuchsia pas
sorti des trucs pour completel enfin bon
il ya plein de gens qui n'ont pas
redonné et je me pose juste la question
parce qu'il est quand même sens et de
bouche alors un type de gauche qui était
une ordure à 20 ans
il ya plein de gens pour pardonner
j'aimerais savoir si quand on voit un
type qui a été d'extrême droite il ya 20
ans qui aura je suis pas à la fac
d'assas course et les les maghrébins
dans la rue d'assas et rue vavin et
c'est avec à coups de rangers c2 et de
matraques
trente ans après il avait changé
maintenant je reste de droite mais j'ai
changé
est ce qu'on va lui rendre de l'est déjà
mais sont devenus ministres dont les
achats ont leur ressort toujours on ne
leur accorde aucun crédit
le mec de droite qui s'expriment jamais
certes il a droit au pardon d'après les
psychanalystes d'après les
psychanalystes on ne change jamais donc
les ordures reste des ordures et les
siens ne raterez l'ex amant ce qui
m'étonne verdure voilà c'est ce gars non
à double détente
c'est assez curieux c'est pas sûr que
les femmes de plus de 50 ans lui
pardonne pas le problème est ce que dans
l'actualité il ya une personnalité que
vous paraît apparaître nôtres au
contraire qui pourrait descendre un
petit peu ça rejoint puisqu'on a dit
pendant pendant une heure c'est à dire
que je n'en suis pas ravi
personnellement mais anne hidalgo semble
surnager
donc elle semble remonter enfin pour
l'instant je veux dire le cauchemar
n'est pas sûr donc ça va et guerrier ne
reçoit pas fini car c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire
l'erreur sans l'arrêt voilà ce serait
drôle et la probable élection les
travaux continuent ça sera ça fera son
slogan nos slogans qu'ils continuent il
ya peut-être parce qu'il ya souvent ça
se dire que ça s'arrête avec l'idée que
les gens vont oublier et pour connaître
aller l'algo quand même une certaine
constance et que l'on peut pas arrêter
les travaux vu qu elle l a éventré tout
paris donc si on arrête ce sera
dramatique faudrait au moins deux ans
pour reboucher tout ce qu'elle a eu tout
ce qu'elle a éventré donc donc là c'est
mort quoi donc
et puis de la personnalité en hausse
enfin en baisse vers mombasa yann moix
effectivement parce que le bon là il
concourait pas nourrir des gens et je
lui pardonne oui c'est un peu trash 1
pour le goncourt
oui non non non non il aura mais même au
delà du le reste peut être sur la liste
du goût et je pense que le quoi les
niveaux au dessus du livre avec un peu
rock'n'roll pour le lecteur de base de
dû beaucoup couper peur que ma les
librairies décennies manille qui aime
beaucoup il ya deux ans qui a raconté le
comment une baby sitter avait tué des
eaux faust pas non plus ah oui oui mais
là c'est presque non mais ça c'est pas
grave cela veut dire yann moix il nous
reste plus qu'une minute 50 à nos jours
juste alors très vite mais en en un mot
est ce que parce que il y avait un
dossier comme ça loeb ce qui était assez
intéressant sur la rentrée scolaire et
sur les profs qui est ce qu'il ya des
profs qui vous ont marqué un prof prof
d'anglais quand j'étais entre épouse est
devenu prendre au chili
pourtant il n'ya pas de hasard français
ce bond qui réussit à avoir
l'entousiasme de toute la classe des
plus mauvais élèves
qui m'a donné le goût aussi du français
après j'ai fait des études littéraires
mais j'ai pas amélioré mon orthographe
est prof grâce à des propres histoires
rencontre d'un professeur de droit
administratif en deuxième année à la fin
c'est incroyable un charme
oui une prof d'histoire géo en seconde
avec lequel on n'a jamais fait un poil
d'histoire ni de géo inquiéter dingue de
cinéma à la face de chaque cours on
aller au ciné club de l'école donc que
j'ai découvert le cinéma grâce à elle
voilà après j'ai fait des études
d'histoire donc j'ai compensé ses
membres mais voilà et la littérature
puisqu'il ya deux les deux dernières
parutions
ça c'est de la commission voilà ouvre
les yeux vers x avait voilà un roman
policier qui paraît assez classique au
départ c'est un type un peu curieux qui
fait partie d'un groupe de parole et qui
emmène son groupe de parole
vers un enlèvement parce qu'il veut
enlever sa fiancée qui est dans le coma
en disant si on l'enlève et je la ramène
vers le lieu où on s'est aimé être à
gaza ville en fait voilà c'est une
cavale absolument génial et en fait je
ne suis pas du tout ça mais c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça ld de
multiples retours de situations
retournement de situation alors mortels
canicule on sait que c'est ça c'est
écrit par le duo françois passe le
shérif de nantes
il est capitaine de police à nantes et
après des années à la police judiciaire
de paris et notamment en 2003 où il
s'est occupé de cette canicule terrible
et il me racontait ce qui est vrai et
vérifié que est tellement de morts
qu'ils avaient réquisitionné des
entrepôts de rungis pour mettre les
morts donc c'est et lui s'est dit à
l'époque qui sont dit mais on n'a pas le
temps de faire notre boulot les légistes
ont pas le temps de faire leur boulot il
ya sûrement des gens qu'on a fait passer
pour mort de chaleur en fait ils sont
morts parce qu'on a mis un oreiller sur
la tête et c'est donc et c'est sûrement
vrai et donc l'histoire et est celle-là
nas das d'un crime
c'est passionnant parce que c'était son
boulot et connaissaient parfaitement
merci beaucoup et qu'il faudrait fille
stéphane mensongère charles lajoie 10 et
à très vite pour un nouveau numéro de
paf
[Musique]